hey everyone it's Mike Wallace and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for October 2nd 2017 and you
know what a day it was it was a new high
in the Dow we were each 22 five five
seven and the big news I think was the
ISF manufacturing report it was actually
one of the strongest on record and it
contrasts with the more moderate results
from the PMI so construction spending
rose in August but there was sharp
weaknesses in the downwardly revised
July edition but nevertheless a nice
update in the SPS
and some nice nice trades to be had with
order flow in you know in the five years
in the bonds and euro currency you know
basically all over the place there's
those nice movements today so let's just
jump into it but before we do a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures contract
futures trading rather contains
potential risk is not for every investor
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading only those
with sufficient risk capital should
consider trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
as usual the tools in this presentation
that I use are the order flows trader
volume footprint chart which is my
version of the footprint chart and the
Delta scalper and the price rejector and
you know within the order flows trader
there are other indicators programmed in
there one of them is the ratios and
divergences and I'll talk about that
today so let's take a look at the five
years here let me get the chart up okay
so five years coming in to the morning
session you know he's after about 7:30
we started rallying making new highs on
a nice strong positive deltas 2000 3000
5000 3600 you get up to this high right
here you've got divergence so you got
negative Delta you've got a bearish
ratio indicating price rejection up in
here with the ratio of fifty nine point
seven two and you know that's that's the
trade right there ratio and divergence I
talked about this pretty much in almost
every single video that I do
trade recaps I show you and again I'm
showing you the same market so you can
see how regularly they appear over time
so you know if you're not using ratios
you're not using divergences you're not
using order flow on your trading
honestly I think you're leaving out a
great form of analysis in your trading
number came out selling came right in
here you got this bar here you got this
you know some stopping volume up in here
twenty one hundred sixteen seventy one
you got selling imbalances here on the
way down and but this was the signal
right here in this bar you know you got
this is happening at 8:47 you see how
the market sold off you get down here
you've got another sign of price
rejection you got the point of control
towards the bottom you've got the Delta
scalper giving you a buy signal and the
market shot up here and then this was a
three in a row you didn't get to pull
back on the entry so you don't get an
entry on a three in a row here
eventually it failed anyway Delta
scalper gave you a little sell here but
not much you know the rest of the day
just sort of range-bound
going into the close and into the
evening session but this was the trade
right here you got your ratio and
divergence right on the high that's it I
could talk about it though I'm blue in
the face people you know are probably
tired of hearing about it but you know
it's there every day now I'm going to
show you the the other version of this
this trade and it occurred in the bonds
it's the ratio and divergence but where
the ratio comes in the bar after the
high is made with the divergence so here
it is similar it's around the same time
actually but this one happens a little
bit sooner
at least the high does and we start
selling off so you have your divergence
here on this high now you do have a
divergence here but the difference is it
came right back with a bullish ratio in
the next bar here you have the
divergence of selling divergence you
know the negative Delta on the high
negative Delta on the high here and here
but this time you've got the bearish
ratio right after it here you have a
bullish ratio after sell divergence
that's not a good sign you know it's I'm
not gonna say that it's a sign the
markets going higher I'm just saying
it's not a sign to get short here you
have the sign to get short you've got
the divergence you've got the
afterwards then you sell off from the 29
area you know all the way down to the
20s before you get the little bounce
back up here you come back up sort of
test the high you get within a tick up
the high selling comes back in here and
you know we work our way down and just
again like the five years just sort of
goes sideways the rest of the session
into the evening session but again you
know there's two versions of it one
there's the the ratio and divergence in
the same bar second version is the
divergence and the ratio in the bar
afterwards you know this is the bonds
the previous one was the five years and
again it's it's it happens just about
every day in just about every market I
don't want to say it happens every day
in every market because then you know
somebody will post a snarky comment so
you know it didn't happen today
you're a liar you know I mean come on
you know you got time to post people got
time to post snarky comments they got
time to learn how to trade so where are
we here this is the euro currency and I
want to talk about this this was early
in the day pretty early what the part
that I want to talk about we just find
it here 5:00 in the morning come down
into this low here right you have a
divergence you don't have a ratio you
don't have a ratio in the bar afterwards
but what I like about this is look at
this volume that's showing up down here
at this low okay this is five in the
morning so keep that in mind when you're
looking at the volume volume at five in
the morning is gonna be different than
volume at 10 a.m. but this is heavy
volume that's telling me there's some
support down here 165 113 200 204 197
you even come down here you test it
again less volume again here you got
less volume then you got originally its
I don't say it's less volume than here
but technically it is just this 23 vs. 7
but the this first bar here is telling
me you know there's some support down
here so we're testing that we're testing
it and what happens you can't get
through it and what happens is the
market rallies you know it rallies from
what is this level you know the 84 level
up to the 94 I show you 118 even Delta's
scalper gives you a sell signal there
you sell off you got the price rejecter
here we do break through the price
rejecter level by a couple
text then we rally back up you got a
signal here at the Delta scalper buy
that didn't work out then you got the
number came out at nine let me just look
for something else if there was any
other signals in here so again you made
a new low by a tick here no you got the
divergence but no ratio Delta scalper
gave you a sell here this one didn't
work out this one here worked out a bit
again it wasn't the greatest move but
you know you're talking to move from 88
up to you know 98 so it's about 20 ticks
and the euro currency before you sold
off again and going into the close
crude oil let's take a look at crude
honestly I haven't looked at the crew
today so I'm kind of curious to see what
it did well what do we got here this is
the 8 range this is the Delta scalper so
I could see there was some signals here
the Delta scalper gives us nice sell
from 50 60 down to the 30 area
you got to buy they got another sell
here for I don't know what that is 15 15
ticks a little buy here so you had a big
move early just before 5
I sure that's about the time I logged in
so I'm not sure if I got an accurate
foot print chart at that time but I'll
pull it up anyway get it up find it
all righty here we go in a sec come back
here yeah so yeah I said this move
coming into these lows here it's just
right I turn down my system right around
this time for that but I know because
the Delta candles won't print if it's
not receiving real-time data but you
know we start coming in here you got
this bar here this was very interesting
you got all selling imbalances pretty
much the entire bar except for two price
levels you know is this a stop being
triggered or is it you know a big seller
sometimes it's hard to tell unless
you're staring at the market and you
could see it you know I tend to think
that it's a combination you had a big
seller coming in here because I know
there was some decent buying here you
can see the volume where is it here 1186
so and then you know somebody else you
know selling here offering it down 692
1044 so I know that there's sellers up
there holding this market at this 32 33
level you know some stuff gets triggered
here and selling as well and we just
work our way down down down I don't
think I have the Delta scalper on this
chart anyway but you get to this low you
got a divergence no no ratios right
afterwards so here's the Delta scalper
gives us a little sell not much you know
we sort of work our way down you know
from this like I said this 5860 area
down into some new lows down here at 30
or you got this Delta scalper giving you
this Buy
unfortunately we do make a new low buy
you know a couple of ticks right here
for ticks three three ticks one two
three then you work your way back up you
have this stack buying imbalance it
fails on you right away again it's not
good when you have a stack vine
imbalanced I get a red candle right
afterwards that's not what you want to
see you want to see a green candle and
then you know in the next two bars you
spend that time underneath this so you
know if you don't have a tight stop you
know like say below the low of this bar
and you know you want to finesse it so
to speak if you're still under it by the
third bar you know I said it's a bind
imbalance you should be trading up here
for it to hold instead you're trading
beneath it in the third bar forget about
it it's not going to
workout most likely and you see how we
started trading down into some new lows
down here here you have a divergence no
racial next bar twenty seven point six
is that a ratio it's not it's a ratio
but it's right on the borderline of what
I like I like something around twenty
eight to thirty twenty seven point six
again you know you're splitting hairs if
you were to round up it'd be twenty
eight you know I don't have a rounding
function so this doesn't show up as
twenty eight shows up as twenty seven
point six but again you know do you want
to take it or not is is up to you some
people will say yes some people will say
no next bar you got the bullish ratio
fifty two point five here you got the
Delta surge kicking in you can see the
Delta increasing 123 637 so you know
right you're off you're low you've got
strong buying coming in here you can see
at nine seventy two 10:28 for 58 then
123 637 1116 and it's it's starting to
pull away a little bit you know you get
a move from you know the 38 area all the
way up to the 5058 area we got the Delta
scalper kicking in then you got a delta
surge here as well I'm just sort of goes
sideways got then you got the Delta
scalper giving a buy sideways sideways
I'm going into the close and into the
evening session
okay so soybeans I talked about some of
these grains really quick it's been a
lot of interest since I've been showing
grain charts actually so this is
soybeans what he got here at this low
yeah
divergence and a ratio well right on the
low what happens we make a move from 958
all the way up to the 1960s not the
greatest of all moves we started coming
back down here you got point of control
at the top come back down you got to
sell any balance there another selling a
balance there to make this new low you
got some support in here 11 23 526 even
down here you got the Sun of balance for
19 to 13 then you start to make this
rally here you hear you have a
divergence you can't see it it's off the
chart here but it's this arrow this bar
is actually very bullish again I talked
about this type of bar in my inner
circle why it's very bullish and you can
see how this market rallied up from
there you know from the nine sixty seven
and a half
back away at the 960 area you get this
bar it's kind of neutral then you work
your way back down and then we close for
the session but you know this is a
definitely a good opportunity here and
this is a decent opportunity here again
is it a big move no but it's a move
right it's a move from 58 up to 60 it's
two cents that's $100 move and you know
one contract so it's equivalent to two
points in the SPS okay so this is we
talked about we really quick since you
know people are all still interested in
grains 830 is the reopen here you have
some volume going through you've got you
know port control on the bottom you got
the ratio and divergence but it's right
on the open even here you have a delta
scalper happening you know this is 838
it's about five eight minutes after the
open reopens at 8:30 I wouldn't take
this trade here this one I might be I'd
probably be interested in it didn't work
out it made a new low dr. search comes
in there you know it's going back and
forth it's kind of a volatile opening
this morning first half hour trading you
made the new low
you got some sell signals some buy
signals I thought you know here you got
the Delta scalper again then it runs
right into a bearish ratio here with
corner control at the top then you get
down into this low but you know say you
again this trade I would not take this
trade I'd probably be taking Delta surge
here you know you know I I'm more
interested in buying than selling going
into a low so I probably wouldn't be
taking that you know Delta a scalper
again here so dr. scalper Delta scalper
these two I'd probably take that get
stopped out on both of them then you got
here Delta scalper giving you a Buy and
it just sort of goes sideways before you
get a little bit of a rally up but it's
still not much happening in the in the
week today kind of a tightest range
since the the open you know since the
open you know you're talking what is
that for for for 44 you know there's
basically been your your your range down
to four thirty nine and a half so a very
tight range in the wheat this morning or
today rather I'm not gonna talk about
corn because corn was I think kind of
boring but just really quick
go back to something that's moving a
little bit Aussie dollar can you know
Aussie dollar is one of those contracts
you don't it doesn't you know I said
unless you're Australian you're probably
not really interested in it okay but
what I want to show you is for you know
for people in my inner circle though
they'll know this I did a presentation I
get it posted up today but this bar here
very bearish bar you know here you have
a three in a row as well but this bar
here very bearish and you get this nice
quick sell-off here when the is M came
out obviously you know Australia is a
big commodity producing number so you
can get some movements but this bar with
very bearish again it just cuz I say
it's very bearish don't expect you know
a thousand point move or anything like
that don't wonder when I say very
bearish I mean he's you know it's an
opportunity to get short again the
capacity of the trade is another story
it may be a lot it may be a little but
just cuz I say you know this is very
bearish does it don't expect a huge move
to me it's like well you know that
that's a very bearish move it's like if
you you know okay like say example if
you follow football English football
English Premier League Soccer's we call
in the US but English Premier League
football right and and you got you know
Manchester United up against QPR you'd
be very bullish on Manchester United
that doesn't mean Manchester United's
gonna be QPR 30 to 0 hit home though
they're happy to eke out a win you know
1 nil or you know 2 to 1 or something
like that just because you're very bull
I say I'm very bearish on something
doesn't mean it's gonna be a monster
move it's it's just that you know I
really like this setup and you know
we'll see how it develops you know over
time you know obviously you start
running down in here you've got some
signs of price rejection here in this
bar opponent controls lining up and you
start working your way up so by this
point I'm off this already so you know
when I say I'm very bearish or very
bullish don't expect it to be well Mike
said he's very bearish on this and you
only got a small move all the markets
develop over the trading day so things
can change
but like this type of bar you know
occurring in a regular
you know setting is very bearish to me
that's the point I'm trying to make then
again you know in the evening session
again this type of bar also very bearish
for me as well and you know we sold off
and went into the evening session sold
off some more okay so the S&P is this
morning SFA is new high so let's take a
look at any of these trading application
so talk about it mostly since the cash
open you know since the cash open
Richard trading neuron lows you got some
Delta scalper buyers coming in here
right off the low and what happens is we
get this nice rally from the eighteen
and a half area all the way up all the
way up to the highs new highs now you
get up here you've got a bunch of stuff
happening up here what do you got you
got divergence you got ratio I just
showed you in the bonds same trade setup
ratio and divergence we'll trade it here
you also got the Delta scalper coming in
the bar right off the high and you know
so you got you know two signals there
you know it's it's trading 24
unfortunate just sort of goes sideways
trades down to 23 22 and 1/2 and goes
sideways before eventually getting the
nice move down you know down here where
you have this bullish bar with the point
of control right at the bottom you have
you know a ratio bounds low there you
get a little bit of a bounce up then you
come down here it's around 11 you got
the swing low here you got this Delta
scalper by you got some nice supportive
volume in this bar afterwards you know
four thousand 2000 1800 at this point
it's all systems go so you went from
supportive buying and this bar to
agressive buying in these next bars here
you know Delta scalper right here now
again you know this is the beauty of the
Dulles Capri a question came in when I
was a delta scalper based on well it's
based on reading the Delta over certain
periods and picking up changes right you
know you're looking at this you know
here you got negative Delta for 298 4000
positive Delta 900 and negative 1200
negative 2400 minus 200 plus 800 you
know that's why I have the Delta scalper
program because if you're looking at
this you'd think it's bearish actually
with all this Delta but you're starting
to see changes in the Delta
coming in and that's what the Delta
scupper does it takes that form of
analysis
your shoulders and does it for you it's
giving you this buy signal here and what
happens when we get this beautiful
signal but again you know even if I
wasn't using Delta scalper you should be
able to pick up the sport of buying here
and it turns to aggressive buying on the
way back up but again from you know 25
20 and a half 20 one area all the way
back up to the twenty five area into
these new high you know these highs up
here again I don't think you'd be
holding it going into the cash close but
after the cash close boom heavy bottom
goes through make the new highs so all
in all it was a you know a pretty good
day with order flow a lot of nice
signals a lot of signals that you see
happening all the time you know and I
said you know and the Delta scalper this
is the beauty of it again it's you know
if you're just looking at this say
you're just looking at this market like
this you're looking at the it's mostly
negative Delta's in here you might think
this markets going down but using a tool
like the Delta scalper is gonna pick it
up that is changing on you that is
actually a buying opportunity rather
than a selling opportunity okay so
thanks everyone for watching this if
you're interested in learning more about
order flow and the trading software
using this presentation you can visit my
website order flow is calm or if wanna
learn more about the deltas scalp and go
to Delta's scalper calm so thanks
everyone have a great day bye-bye